blocking some checks but  I don't think you can  exploit these checks much longer  actually if you block with the queen now  for whites you risk losing so okay you  step back  yeah these guys just enjoying the moment  trying to get as many moves as possible  yeah just insisting now on the draw  what's Magnus doing just he's been lucky  if anything to escape this game yeah  like I think he's just playing out of  pure inertia and frustration basically I  think he's just annoyed I think he's  I think he you know if you ask him how  he played today he'll be  very uh  strong with his language about his  performance he knows he's played very  poorly today and there we go the result  is confirmed and what is that laughter  about from Magnus Carlson do you think  maybe he had Lawrence talking about it  maybe  I laugh from Magnus Carlsen he's  finishing